all right carrie
terry where'd you grow up where are you
from originally
huh
where are you from i'm from l.a
what part
california
okay and uh tell me about your family
growing up you had mom and dad um i have
i have lost care parents
first killed parents i don't know where
my mom and my real dad is
so you went to the foster system yes all
right
pretty much right after birth yes
and how was that for you
terrible
because my first kill dad molested me
how long did i go on
for a while yeah
yeah nobody does protect you no
i must lost come on didn't do nothing
about it
and then where did your life go
how long were you there
four
since
13
13 you did what you ran away yes
where'd you go
i ran away
and then they took me too fast to kill
and how were you there
for like
almost
like five months or more
what happened then you were you
then after that i just got um turned out
by pimps
and then started being across two
and then i never can stop
and i've been doing it from hollywood
downtown and south central
how old are you now
47.
you're still doing it today yes
because my little income is not
um helping me i'm on
disability and it's not enough
you've been working with pimps all along
yes i have
and i've been abused and i've been
through a lot of
abuse relationship well um
i got beat up my my um
my nose been broken my tailbone been
broken i jumped out cars
and they was trying to hit me
when you're working with pimps are you
keeping any of the money or
no giving it all to them
so
i'm trying to figure out why you would
stay with them
i'm not staying with them no more about
myself now you work by yourself man yeah
[Music]
you have kids
i have three kids
where are they one is with the father
and one two is with my mom
and you're staying on skid row
well i have section eight but i come
down here to work
oh i see
and i work in hollywood
[Music]
and drugs are part of your life
yes
and it's just um i've been trying to
stop and i just relapse
every time what is your drug
um
crack and cocaine
and crystal
how long have you had your
housing
um
since last november of christmas
and before before you had that housing
where were you staying i've been staying
in a tent since 92
being homeless
here in skid row
no in hollywood no i would and then came
down here
being homeless
you still have contact with your kids
yeah
it's a very lo very rough lifestyle
isn't it yes it is very life worth
lifestyle
i'm sure it affects you emotionally yes
it's yes
you assume you get depressed a lot yeah
i've been getting depressed a lot and
down
what's the hardest part of doing this
living this life for you
living my life is prostitution and drugs
what's the
what's the hardest part for you to go
through the hardest part is going
through the hard time and emotional
did you you ran away at 13 how far did
you go to school
up to 12th grade you graduated high
school i didn't graduated i stopped
have you ever had a job or have you
always done this kind of work i never
had a job because i'm on disability
what is your disability his speech
problem
and then i'm wanted for because i've
been abused a lot
is this the hardest part of your life
right now yes it is very hard of my life
right now
because i'm just going through it
do you have any friends
um all my friends is street friends
and then i really don't have a family
all my um families out here is my play
families
what do you worry about i'm just
wondering about if i can get well and
try to go to a program because i keep
relapsing
doing this kind of work you've had bad
things happen to you
yeah i had bad things happen to me i've
been awake
i've been i've been abused i've been
beat up
and i've been getting taken advantage of
from people
and then i don't have no dad i call my
family dads out here
you don't have my i don't have no dad
i don't have no dad
tell me about the pimps that you've
worked with
gyms i've been working in hollywood
but tell me what it's like to work with
them terrible because they like to beat
up on females
and the tricks that you work
your customers the customers
is okay sometimes you have to take a
chance because they cannot
mean
and you gotta watch yourself when
nobody's out there watching i'm taking a
lot of chances
what kind of things have happened with
the tricks got knives pulled out on me
guns pulled out on me
do you feel like you were
you weren't given any other
options or choices when you were no
because when uh when i was 13
one of my friends took me to hollywood
and i got introduced to one pimp and i
couldn't stop then
you couldn't stop because you couldn't
get out or because i know is this
another reason because my dad molested
me and that's why i've been doing it you
feel like that kind of
led you into it yeah
it's a horrible thing to go through as a
young girl yes
do you feel like you were ever loved
no i don't feel like i'm in love
i don't feel like i have been loved by
nobody because i've been abused
and like i told you i have played family
out there and i i know
and always on my play family
i don't get no love from nobody else
do you think you deserve a better life
than this yeah i think i'm so bad alive
it's just hard because i can't quit and
i'm trying to talk to my play families
to help me
and i got three kids
were you ever in their lives regularly i
wasn't i was in their lives since they
was kids and then after that i've been
messing up
would you blame the drugs yeah is that
why
you tried to get clean before um no i
haven't been trying to get clean before
it's just i don't want to go to no
program because last time i went to a
program and i didn't finish it and i
left and
and then i know that if i go again i'm
gonna relapse and then leave again
do you have hope of a better life
yes
just in case
you can imagine getting
getting clean from the drugs i'm trying
to get clean from the drugs that's why
i'm trying to talk to my play family
they can help me
you started working as a prostitute at
13. yes
what was it like working as a young
underage girl
terrible
in what ways
huh in what ways
just just when you get
when you get met to the game like that
when you when you're little
since 13 you just
and then
and then it's terrible
did the pimps kind of encourage you to
stay on the drugs or no they don't
the pimps don't help
did they encourage you to stay on the
drugs or try to help you get off um they
just they encourage me staying doing
drugs
how did you first get introduced to
drugs well the first time i got
introduced to him when i was with a guy
and he got me hooked on him
a guy oh like a boyfriend boyfriend yes
what do you think living this life has
taught you about
about people
the life that taught me by people
um to just stay strong
out there and have your head lift up
and don't do nothing stupid
do you have anyone you can trust
um really i don't have nobody to i have
nobody to trust only my play family
when you say your play family you mean
people on the streets yeah like on the
streets
carrie what would you say is the most
important thing you've learned in your
life
important thing in my life
is when i was at home with my kids
what did you learn
to be a mom and take care of him
but the drugs kind of get in the way
it's not because the drugs got in my way
is because the false was abusive
oh the father of the kids yes
you have any regrets in your life
yes i have regrets in my life because i
don't have my kids with me right now
all right carrie well thank you so much
for sharing your story
okay i wish you the best of luck okay
getting get away from here and getting
clean
okay thank you very much
you